[Music]
it's a day to honor U.N troops who've
given their lives to keeping
International Peace last year at least
32 blue helmets were killed in targeted
attacks
the Democratic Republic of the Congo and
Mali have seen the most fatalities a
trend continuing this year marking the
75th anniversary of U.N peacekeeping
operations
in both countries after years of
instability there have been
demonstrations calling for the troops to
leave the man who oversees 87 000
peacekeepers is quick to defend them he
says there's a perception problem
there's a discrepancy between the
expectations and what we can do and even
what we could do with the best level of
equipment resources which we don't have
for Millions around the world in places
ravaged by conflict peacekeepers May
stand between life and death but they
face a broad set of challenges often
caught between countries that want them
to do more in an international
organization that wants them to do so
with less
the UN has warned violent extremism is a
growing threat in Africa particularly in
the sub-Saharan Sahel region the
increase in attacks against civilians
and civilian infrastructure
mean that we have more to do
we believe that the evolution of the
protection of civilians in peacekeeping
mandates from initially being a minor
component of mission mandates to now
becoming one of the principal objectives
of peacekeeping is one that must be
reinforced France once a major troop
contributor to the region recently
pulled out its forces after facing more
attacks and backlash from their
inability to stop them analyst Richard
Gowan says the U.N is in a difficult
position its troops are under attack and
it doesn't really have the military
capabilities or the political leverage
to enforce peace in Africa in particular
we're seeing governments that are
disillusioned with un peacekeeping
turning to Alternative security
providers at divided Security Council
makes negotiating new mandates and
finding new funding a challenge
especially in Mali the state to school
is not an option even for one reason
which is that it's a mission that is
overstretched its mandate was extended
three years ago to the center of Mali
but there were no corresponding
additional resources that were provided
without those resources he warns nations
in Conflict will have to look elsewhere
for help Kristen salumi Al Jazeera the
United Nations